[Music]
welcome back so in this lecture we're
gonna determine the eigen face basis to
represent all human faces based on this
large library of example images from the
alb face data set so again we have 36
individuals that we're going to use to
train or to build this embedding and for
each of those individuals we have 64
different lighting conditions so for
each of those individuals so that's a
massive data matrix X each column is one
of these faces reshaped into a tall
vector and I have about 2,400 of those
columns corresponding to these 2,400
pictures okay so now what we're going to
do is we're going to actually compute
the eigen faces okay so again you're
gonna load this this faces database
you're going to compute the mean face
you're gonna you're gonna compute the
average column vector in X the average
face and subtract it from all faces and
then we're going to compute the SVD of
that mean Center data X and so this is
very much related to the principal
components because we're doing an SVD on
mean Center data okay so this is the
this step right here where we take the
SVD of X of course we're gonna do the
economy SVD so we don't want full
matrices we just want the part that
corresponds to nonzero singular value
and then we're gonna plot the average
face and the modes these eigen modes and
again I should probably be explicit if a
column vector of X came from an image so
essentially I reshaped an image into a
tall skinny column vector then the
column vectors of you have the same size
as a column vector of X so these column
vectors of you can also be reshaped into
I gain faces into these kind of
orthonormal basis faces and that's what
we're going to be plotting and computing
here okay
so when I run this code these are
essentially like the first two eigen
faces eigenfaces that you get
okay and they look like these ghosty
kind of funny
yeah like ghost faces and there are lots
of these there are 2400 of these eigen
face columns and you would essentially
take a linear combination of these eigen
faces in these columns of U and that
would recover an image of person 1 or an
image of person 2 and so every person's
face and every every image of a person's
face is a linear combination of these
eigen faces of these kind of weird
ghosty eigenfaces that will capture
different features and different shadows
and things like that okay and so what
you can end up doing with this is you
can take a new image so if I have a test
image a test image X and this is gonna
be from a person that I did not include
in my original library then what I can
do is I can project them into my eigen
face space so I can take the first R
columns of U are by our block of Sigma
and our columns of V and then this will
be approximately true so this is u R
transpose and if I take X and I take its
inner product with the first R columns
of u I get a little a little R
dimensional vector I like to call alpha
okay this is a little vector alpha and
alpha is essentially the mixture of
these modes that you need to reconstruct
X so it's the amount of mode one in this
person's face and then the amount of
mode two in this person's face and mode
three and four and so on and so forth
and so this alpha is kind of like a
fingerprint in this eigen space space
that you can use to reconstruct people's
faces and then if you want to go from
that little alpha back to a high
dimensional X you just multiply it by
you are transpose you take that alpha
that combination and those columns of u
are
and you get back to an image so
essentially what I want to do is if I
take you R times u R transpose times X I
get an approximation of X in this
subspace faces and this eigen face
subspace okay so it's a lot of math I
said that pretty quickly but the basic
idea is that maybe I needed a megapixel
to represent all of these peoples faces
that's a million pieces of information
but if I find that just the first 500
columns of U are good enough to
approximate most people's faces if that
gives me a good faithful reconstruction
then I don't have to store a million
pixels for each new person's face I just
have to store this alpha vector with 500
numbers that tells me the combination of
eigenfaces I need to add up to make that
new face and so this is a huge
compression instead of a million numbers
I just need to carry around 500 numbers
okay
now the catch is that if you want to use
this for compression we would all have
to agree on the library or the basis you
and we'd all have to have a copy of that
but if we all agreed on that and had a
copy then if I wanted to send you a
picture of a face I would just send you
alpha and you could decode it with with
this you are library okay it's actually
kind of how the Fourier transform image
compression or wavelet image compression
works we all agree on the basis and then
we just send the coefficients of the
basis okay so this is another way of
thinking about it and so what I'm gonna
do now is I'm gonna take this was
trained on the first 36 people now I'm
gonna take an image from person 37 that
was not used to train this library and
I'm gonna see how his face looks when I
project it down into a subspace and then
reconstruct with those modes and I'm
gonna vary are from like 25 50 hundred
200 400 800 and so on and hopefully we
can faithfully represent his face as if
we increase the number of modes to
something reason
okay so that's what we're gonna do here
is basically I'm gonna take a new face
from person 37 that's this index starts
at 0 so this is the 37th person and what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to build up a
reconstruction of his face using the
first 25 or 50 or a hundred and so on
modes so our is gonna vary and the
reconstructed face is super simple it's
just I have to add back the average face
plus u sub R times use of our transpose
times my test face this thing right here
okay and if I do that what you find is
let me see here this is the original
face it's kind of inverted color scheme
and fact you'd probably invert that
right now let me just do that okay so
let me rerun this this is going to take
a minute but I want this to actually
look good so we're gonna rerun the first
part okay good and then we're gonna
rerun the second part and it's gonna
take a little bit because this is a
pretty big matrix to load and compute
the SVD F
okay good so all I did was I subtracted
200 and had subtracted my image from 256
this is because to get this black
background I've inverted the the color
scheme on my laptop so you wouldn't need
this 256 - but it looks better now okay
good so this is my original image of
person 37 and we're going to look at the
reconstruction with a rank 25
reconstruction doesn't look anything
like him okay rank 50 still doesn't look
like him let's see it's probably still
computing more rank 100 so this is
pretty expensive to multiply all of
these matrices and recombine them like
this is this is a very expensive matrix
operation and now that I think about it
I hope that I'm multiplying it in this
order and then multiplying this that
would be a lot more efficient than if I
multiplied you are you are transposed
first and then multiplied X so I'm gonna
go check the code later and make sure
I'm not doing something something bad
here are 200 is getting closer so this
actually is starting to look a little
bit more like like our person here and
it's just getting better and better and
better with 400 modes 800 mode 1600
modes this is gonna look more and more
like like our persons of 400 modes and I
actually think that this is kind of a
phase change happens around 400 modes
where it really starts to look like the
person so you could almost pick out this
person in a lineup if you were given
this 400 mode representation of his face
okay and if we include more and more and
more modes it's only gonna get better
and better and better but what this
indicates is that you can get away with
a relatively small amount of information
in this this vector a all you need is
400 pieces of information that you would
then use to reconstruct the image by
multiplying with you are
and again it's just getting better the
more modes you you include okay good so
we can reconstruct a new person in this
orthogonal eigen face space which is
pretty interesting so this orthogonal
basis of eigenfaces can actually be
useful to represent new people's faces
okay thank you